the French president is at the White
House today that's big news okay clearly
you don't think so that's true not our
president huh no it's just kind of a big
deal sure yeah French president the
White House when president Emmanuel
macron greeted President Trump he kissed
Trump on both cheeks yeah then out of
habit Michael Cohen showed up and hinted
McCrone 130,000 dollar
you keep your mouth shut
I was going on White House physician dr.
Ronnie Jackson has been accused of
drinking on the job yeah
today Jackson defended himself saying
you drink too if you saw Donald Trump
naked
just sitting there yeah all right have a
look huh yeah he probably had to touch
him - yeah yeah oh yeah various probes
[Music]
this morning enough you saw this the
internet just erupted after Melania
Trump was photographed wearing a Beyonce
style hat yeah yeah and just like
Beyonce Melania is recording an album
about her cheating husband so that's
called orangeade even Trump's listening
I like it old babies in the news old
Navy has announced plans to open 60 more
stores this year 60 more old navies yeah
this is great news for guys who say I
love khakis I just wish they fell apart
faster sorry like what's he got against
old Navy
well they fall apart check it out do
they buy ads on the show Jeff oh they do
Old Navy very good
that's a long-lasting khaki Andy oh my
god it lasts too long if you ask me yeah
now we're in trouble again thanks a lot
in Santa Monica that's right Santa
Monica a man was arrested for
masturbating during an uber ride yeah
yeah the driver got suspicious when the
man kept saying arriving in two minutes
wait make that one minute
are they update all right that's why my
monologue should add all right
you